we want to get to a major interview off
the top here at our eight o'clock hour
major Revelations from a former advisor
to the January 6 investigation uh
regarding the Trump White House and what
was going on inside their former
Republican Congressman Denver riegelman
served on the January 6 committee as a
technical advisor for eight months until
he left in April of this year he is also
a former military intelligence officer
and a consultant for the NSA and he lays
all this out in a new book it's called
the breach the untold story of the
investigation into January 6. it's an
inside account of his time working with
the committee it was his job to analyze
the digital records from that day
including white house phone calls in an
interview with Bill Whitaker last night
for 60 Minutes riggleman claims that the
White House switchboard connected to a
rioter's phone during the riots on
January 6. take a listen
did it hit you at one point this is way
bigger than it appeared in the beginning
absolutely do you get a real aha moment
when you see that the White House
switchboard had connected to a rioter's
phone while it's happening that's a big
pretty big aha moment you get aha wait a
minute
someone in the White House was calling
one of the rioters while the riot was
going on on January 6th absolutely and
you know who both ends of that call I
only know one end of that call I don't
know the White House end which I believe
is more important but the thing is the
American people need to know that there
are link connections that need to be
explored more
oh boy Denver riggleman joins us now uh
Congressman thank you very much for
being here that's an explosive sound
bite and I want to get into the details
of that White House call but first big
picture because where my mom lives in
West Virginia where you're from in
Virginia where your folks are from in
West Virginia as well they may not even
know that there is a committee
investigating January 6. and if they
have heard of it they think it was a
peaceful demonstration where a couple
people got out of hand much to do about
it they don't care at all they don't
care so so from where you're sitting as
a former Republican Congressman uh
what's the reality for people well the
reality you know for us we we have this
sort of microcosm uh you know owning
distilleries you know in Virginia and
Pennsylvania we have tens of thousands
of people come through and since I've
been on the committee most people don't
even know about it they don't know that
there's a committee report coming they
just think January 6 was this little
thing that happened and we needed to
move on and really you know it probably
was just a bunch of people who wanted to
save America and we're Patriots and you
know that's something that you know one
of the reasons that I wrote the book and
sort of this narrative fashion trying to
break down facts and what information
Warfare means is because I had those
discussions with people and I got to
tell you even today seems like they're
even more I would say ignorant about
what's going on with the committee than
they were when we first started and I
think that's a that's a real problem you
say it was an Insurrection an attempted
coup and that it was highly coordinated
yes that call there where from the White
House someone inside the White House
while the riot is going on it places a
call to the rider you know who the
writer is any idea on who it might have
been in the White House and any other
details you can share about this call
how long it was right et cetera yeah it
wasn't a very long call I mean that's
one of the things it was it was less
than 10 seconds but what I want to
explain to the American people look at
the switchboard is the tech right it's a
desk phone somebody called something
called a call manager Works its way
through the call manager and really it
strips that regular phone number and
adds just a default number so say you're
calling from CBS News you don't want
people to know your desk phone so it
just sets to a default number so when I
say to the switchboard it's just a
switchboard number so really the call is
just from a desk phone to somebody right
who's a doj charge defendant is it
possible it could be the president who
made that call I yeah I I would say it's
probably not probable you know um but on
the other hand how would we don't know
what those extensions or those numbers
are but Jenny we should talk about
the information that you got that's what
I think is so astounding right you said
let you Tell the readers you don't care
if you don't care if they like you or
trust you just pay attention to the data
right because what you did is astounding
can you just be you looked at number one
Mark Meadows you said handed over the
crown jewels it was like staring into
the mouth of Madness right because by
looking at text looking at phone explain
exactly what you did briefly how it
worked sure when we first started you
know it took a little while to get
started but they asked me to build these
technical teams and what I had to do was
find people a lot smarter than me so I
went out people that had worked with you
know some three-letter agencies before
or people had done this kind of work and
you have an intelligence background
important yeah it's just only about 20
years you know and uh so um you know
just a little a lot of data analytics
you know NSA United States Air Force
offices Secretary of Defense did some
crazy things in my life right
um so I got a little bit of a background
you know but uh I think what happened
was I needed to find some real
incredible individuals and what we did
is we built these teams I built the
contracts for them wrote the technical
specs for them and now these guys guys
went out and did some amazing work and
what they did was they had to actually
match all those text numbers to the name
to names what names are they then when
we started getting called detail records
They had to look at all those link
connections and right now we're probably
close to 20 million lines of data but
this is coming at Great personal apparel
to you you're getting death threats
insults your truck was sabotaged even
your own mother turned against you in a
text you said you know it was like it
was a punch to the gut your mom said
what happened to you what's wrong with
you I'm sorry you were elected you're
not smarter than the truth this is your
own mother who doesn't believe you right
and that's you know and that's what I I
cover is that this this sort of
information Warfare this digital
metastasization of crazy where it can
get everywhere right and people are
looking at things that just don't make
sense or they think well that that's if
it's the President telling me and all
the people around him it's obviously
have to be true it's just not it's
hogwash and you know as I go in that
chapter finds out that you know the love
for my mother and her love for me will
overcome that and it did overcome it but
what I wanted to explain to people is
that there's so many families that are
are almost in trauma trying to talk to
individuals about something that is is
absolutely not true right it's a
falsehood it's just not true there's no
there's no parsing it it's just sort of
it's just not true there's just real
parsing it right um You left the
Republican Party earlier this year and
you said you discovered some evidence
that influenced your decision right to
do that what evidence did you discover
you know I I I thought I had this
inkling that I could be some kind of new
Republican I didn't get into politics
when I was 47 what is your definition of
a new Republican I thought the new
Republic was sort of this libertarian
Ben right once I did the same-sex
wedding you know I was for the
legalization of marijuana oh my God you
know that was that went really well in
Central Virginia but uh you know so
there were some things I thought that
you know Freedom right this individual
liberty you know we're not a party
that's just small enough to fit in the
bedroom right right you know that kind
of stuff so but what happened was is
that I found out is I just really wasn't
a really good tribal guy right I started
to I started to Buck the system little
bit it's my fault you know I lost right
so but the thing was the text messages
is what really switched it for me was
looking at those text messages finally
I'm like you know what if if Q Anon or
these conspiracy theories have saturated
the GOP at the highest levels of
leadership I think maybe it's time for
me to go from this type of crazy
Congressman your former colleagues on
the January 6 committee they seem to be
portraying you as a small part of the
overall effort uh that's the message
they're sending to the American public
why do you think they're doing that oh I
think you know I think what's happened
is you know as if you look at this book
it's just about the data I'm not sure
why they're doing that I think they need
to read the book and understand this
isn't a critique of the committee at all
I think there was some fear there there
shouldn't be because what this data does
it supports the incredible work of the
committee let me tell you at the
beginning I was a little nervous right I
was looking at how slow it was moving at
the beginning but once the committee got
going and you saw that first hearing
holy cow right right these are heroes
right I would go to war with the people
on this staff they're amazing
individuals and that's why listen I'm
not a social show path my feelings
actually I know it's hard to believe
with you know my amazing physique but my
my uh my feelings actually do get hurt
sometimes you know and I'm like come on
this this data actually supports the
heroes behind the door and you know
that's why I love it Danny you say
you're not a sociopath but you do call
yourself a full-blooded Red Knot
it's being a full-blooded redneck a good
thing yeah if you know how you know if
you know how to work on a 390 high
compression engine you're a full-blooded
net redneck but I think you know I think
um you know I think it's an old that's a
stupid joke I'm sorry but I think that's
uh that's what happens is listen if I
would they're going to take us off
they're going to take us off here I love
you I'm sorry I'm sorry sorry uh the
book is a real page Turner it's called
the breach it goes on sale tomorrow
right now it is 8 10. time to check your
local weather thank you guys appreciate
it